there's no such thing to me as an
embarrassing moment no such thing if I
tripped and fell if my bra strap showed
if my slip fell off if I fell flat on my
face there's no such thing as an
embarrassing moment because I know that
there is not a moment that I could
possibly experience on the air that
somebody else hasn't already experienced
so when it happens you say oh my slip
fell off and it's it's no big deal
I say to the my girls all of the time
that your real work is to figure out
where your power base is and to work on
the alignment of your personality your
gifts that you have to give with the
real reason why you're here
so that's the number one thing you have
to do work on yourself until your self
up and keep your cup full keep yourself
full now I used to be afraid of that I
used to be afraid particularly from
people who say oh she said she's so full
of herself she's so close and now I
embrace it I considered a compliment
that I am full of myself because only
when you're full I'm full I'm
overflowing my cup runneth over I have
so much to offer and so much to give and
I am not afraid of honoring myself it's
miraculous when you think about it you
just watched two amazing clips from
Oprah Winfrey take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]